What happens when 800 of the world's most elite footballers
and their managers live together under one roof?
Players stop being polite
and start getting Re-al.
This is
The Champions.
-Watch out!
Santa Klopp is coming to town!
-I like my candy canes Harry.
-Hmmm. I suppose I should ask Santa for a real passport.
-What gift can you give a man who has it all?
-Uh, humility?
-Oh, how much is that? I’ll buy 100 humilities.
-It’s a holly jolly lolly golly Christmas Day!
-Ding dong ding dong
-Fa la la la la la la la!
-Shoo! Shoo! Get out of here, Europa House urchins!
Ew.
Ooo, ooh.
I love Cristiano-mas.
It's a time to put aside our differences
and receive expensive gifts.
Oooo! What is this? It's a squishy trophy.
Is it, uh,
(sniffs)
is it supposed to smell like this?
-All right, all right, this one is for you, Robert.
-Oh cool, my dudes, you should not have!
Wow, it’s so big! It must be a-
a Ballon d'Or?
-Well, we figured you deserved it this year anyway and-
-Oh, wait wait wait. Hold on, hold on.
Who are you to just give someone the Ballon d'Or?
-I mean, he was the top scorer in the Bundesliga
and the Champions League this year
and Bayern won the treble so-
-OK, well if we're all just giving the awards to our teammates,
uh, Ronaldo! For, uh, having the most Instagram followers,
you get the Ballon d'Or. Here.
-No! Messi gets the Ballon d'Or
for putting up with Bartomeu.
-(Grunting)
-Give me that.
-Give it back you-
-Well, if we’re giving out the Ballon d'Or,
I want the Lev Yashin Award for best goalkeeper!
-Oh, like you would win!
-I want a Grammy!
-I want the Nobel Peace Prize, man!
-Oh, fart you!
-(Shouting)
-(Whistle blow)
-Here’s how we will settle this.
We will all get dressed up and gather in the auditorium
and I will host this year's Ballon d’Or.
It will be a very tasteful ceremony
as long as everybody follows my rules.
OK?
Here are the rules!
Nine men enter!
One man leaves!
BEGIN!
-(Shouting)
-Who run Barca-town?!
-Wait. I don't get it,
what are the teams?
-I am very confused!
-Should half of us take our shirts off or something?
-Why did you call it Beyond Ballon D'ome
when all the important stuff happens
inside the Ballon D'ome?
-Yeah, I guess I got carried away
with all the cool costumes and production design
and didn’t really think the rest of this concept through.
OK, OK, new rules.
How 'bout this:
Four men enter.
Two men leave.
Those men advance to the knockout round.
We do this eight times.
Then we take those 16 men
and put their names in a pot-
-Hey look! It's snowing!
-Woah, snowflakes.
-Snow.
-Oh, it makes me so happy.
I love the snow.
It's a white Christmas.
-I hate to be the interpreter of bad news,
but that is just asbestos from the roof.
-Oh no.
-Awww.
-Not snow?
-Now I'm sad.
-Dang it.
-Guys, what are we doing?
It's Christmas.
We shouldn't be fighting over some award,
we should be coming together.
-Kevin.
-Kevin's right.
Robert, if anyone deserves the Ballon d'Or,
it's you, man.
You earned it.
-Thank you, guys, that means a lot.
And while I 100 percent deserve the award,
2020 has been hard on everybody.
So how about this year we all share da Ballon d'Or?
-(Cheering)
-Christmas! Christmas!
-Gifts! Gifts!
-Oh yeah!
--Everybody's a GOAT!
-The Christmas spirit. I love it!
-(Clears throat)
-VAR bless us, everyone.
-Ho Ho
(Yelling)
-I need a break after being stuck here forever
doing other people's laundry.
When booking my trip, I sometimes wonder,
"What else could possibly go wrong?"
I mean, that probably won't happen.
But if my plans have to change
it doesn't matter
because Hotels.com has flexible booking options.
Hotels.com.
Because just in case.
-Like and subscribe to B/R Football
or I'll kick you in the jingle balls.